[Musique]
on
alors la question faut-il plus de
biodiversité
l'humanité se crée une période maximale
ou la biodiversité était maximale
associé à une diversité de plantes à
fleurs et afrique on consomme l'humanité
s'est servi de cette biodiversité pour
se nourrir pour survivre pour se soigner
pour s'habiller
mais cette biodiversité est mise à mal
25 % des espèces de mammifères à
l'échelle de la planète sont menacés 80%
des insectes en europe des populations
d'insectes en europe ont disparu en
moins de trente ans même les espèces
communes des paysages agricoles
cultivées régresse comme l'alouette des
champs comme la perdrix grise qui a
connu une diminution de 80 % de ses
effectifs
donc en à peine 25 ans nous sommes tous
conscients de cette perte de
biodiversité
nous l'avons tous observé vécu nous
avons tous connu les pare brise très
sale
avec ces insectes colmatée il fallait
même s'arrêter arrêté sa voiture pour
nettoyer le pare brise pour reprendre la
route l'été donc nous savons tous donc
moi en tant que scientifique
en tant qu'enseignant en tant que
naturaliste
j'ai une forte responsabilité
d'engagement la responsabilité est
importante
six mois si vous étudiants où on ne
s'engage pas vers un autre monde par un
autre système
mais derrière le changement ne se fera
pas la résilience se fera pas donc c'est
pour ça que je fais ce tedx ici c'est
pas en tant que scientifique
c'est vraiment en tant que personne qui
doit s'engager qui a la responsabilité
de
donc interrompt sow intéressons nous aux
causes de cette perte de biodiversité et
surtout aux solutions
ok donc ce soir je vous présenter les
principales causes de perte de
biodiversité et surtout les solutions
qui nous concerne tous ses causes
vous savez pour certains c'est la
destruction des habitats par les
exploits l'exploitation de ressources
naturelles
c'est donc cette dégradation l'habitat
par la pollution
c'est aussi les invasions biologiques
par des espèces exotiques envahissantes
qui s'installent dans des nouvelles
aires géographiques et qui sont hyper
compétitrice et qui ont leur compétition
leur réussite d'invasion leur raison de
l'invasion est expliquée par un band
d'ennemis naturels donc certaines
maladies certains insectes comme le
frelon asiatique qui va causer la
mortalité des abeilles
certaines plantes exotiques s'installer
vont causer une perte de biodiversité
puisque nous appuient qu'elle il ya
aussi la surexploitation de ressources
naturelles notamment sur la surpêche
on va justement exploiter plus
intensément et notamment une
exploitation qui au delà de la capacité
de reproduction de l'espèce
donc c'est bien connu on a de nombreuses
espèces dans la mer qui périclite par
cette surexploitation
on a aussi l'impact des changements
climatiques sur la biodiversité
on sait que un tiers de cette
biodiversité est menacée d'extinction
donc d'ici 30 ans sous cet effet des
changements climatiques
cependant peut-on démontrer les facteurs
qui causent qui sont à l'origine de ces
causes qui sont à l'origine de cette
perte de biodiversité dans un paysage et
plusieurs facteurs qui varient multi
facteurs qui va l échelle de la planète
il ya des multiples facteurs qui
et on pourra montrer que des relations
de cette perte de biodiversité dans le
temps et dans l'espace
on pourra pas dire c'était lé facteur
qui va vraiment un pacte et on pourra
émettre que l'hypothèse et avoir des
arguments scientifiques pour dire
attention il faut donc s'engager et
développer des mesures de précaution
avoir ce courage politique et faire le
choix de développer des mesures de
précaution nous sommes déjà en marche
pour ça et notamment en réintroduisant
de la naturalité dans nos systèmes dans
nos systèmes de production dans nos
systèmes de transformation et dans notre
consommation dans nos usages
tout d'abord c'est de par nos actions de
tous les jours nous en tant que
habitants de la planète en tant
qu'habitant nos territoires nous pouvons
mener nos actions nos actions de tous
les jours nos actions de consommateurs
c'est de réduire la consommation de
ressources naturelles non renouvelables
notamment issus d'énergies fossiles par
exemple réduire toute cette consommation
plastique qui vont causer
il va causer en fait énormément
d'impacts environnementaux qui va se
retrouver dans les micro plastiques qui
vont retrouver se retrouver dans les
ressources en eau dans les sols dans la
chaîne alimentaire et dont on ne connaît
pas encore leur toxicité
c'est aussi donc réduire les donc aller
vers un zéro déchet en réduisant ses
emballages en réduisant en favorisant le
compostage
c'est réduire donc la consommation de
produits ménagers de produits
cosmétiques naturels qu'on utilise
régulièrement et qui vont se transférer
aussi dans les eaux les sols et la
chaîne alimentaire est aussi les
médicaments les antibiotiques
bien sûr ce sont des innovations
pharmaceutique
mais derrière il faut les utiliser de
manière curative et exceptionnelle
puisqu'on va les retrouver aussi dans
les eaux de surface dans les eaux
souterraines
dans les sols dans la chaîne alimentaire
on verra on reviendra sur cette notion
de curatif exceptionnel à nous de le
faire aussi en votant consommateurs mais
aussi à voir comment ça peut être
déployée dans d'autres contextes
c'est aussi de réduire en fait les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et les
particules fines
on a une qualité de l'air qui va
impacter en fait la santé humaine mais
aussi la santé de tout biodiversité
on en parle très peu mais derrière c'est
donc incité le transport en commun et le
covoiturage est aussi rentré dans une
économie fonctionnelle de
fonctionnalités c'est à dire d'acheter
des produits avec une longue durée de
vie
acheter ses produits à longue durée de
vie qui pourront être prêtés vendus
loués et qui pourront aussi comme on a
connu par le passé se transmettent de
génération en génération
la deuxième chose c'est de remettre de
la naturalité en agriculture c'est
pareil il ya des choses qui sont déjà en
cours et déjà des belles évolutions
s'est développé des méthodes
alternatives basées sur des innovations
du vivre on a beaucoup connu innovation
mécanique innovation chimiques et on est
dans l'ère de l'innovation biologique et
technologique
c'est aussi donc pour réduire tous ces
produits donc les produits
phytosanitaires et aussi comme nous
quand nous soignons les utiliser de
manière exceptionnelle et curative donc
se dire que ce n'est pas une
interdiction c'est de savoir les
utiliser au bon moment et au bon endroit
à très faible très faible dose
c'est d'augmenter aussi la diversité
végétale dans les systèmes cultivés dans
le temps et dans l'espace
c'est à dire associer plusieurs espèces
végétales dont certaines vont rentrer
service à l'autre c'est aussi de
diversifier les cultures dans le temps
c'est à dire qu'une culture se succède à
une autre on a une diversité dans le
temps et cet ensemble en fait de
succession rendez service l'une d'une
culture à la suivante notamment en
amenant de la zot
naturellement donc par la réduction de
l'azoté atmosphérique en azote organique
notamment diminuant les risques de
développement de mauvaises herbes et en
réduisant ainsi les produits les
herbicides des produits phytosanitaires
donc ceci doit se développer avec une
économie dynamique donc notamment avec
des filières les nouvelles filières qui
se développeront au niveau national au
niveau local autour de cette
diversification cette biodiversité
végétale s'est développée aussi des
pratiques de conservation des sols
c'est de conserver l'habitat de la
biodiversité du sol et conserver les
fonctions du sol en réduisant son
travail du sol et en l'associant avec
découvert vivant avec des dés des
litières aussi de résidus qui vont
favoriser la fertilité du sol et
conserver ses fonctions
c'est aussi choisir des variétés
sélectionner des variétés qui vont
s'adapter à ces enjeux agro écologiques
notamment des variétés résistantes à des
maladies des variétés peu consommatrices
d'eau des variétés peu consommatrices
d'intrants qui sont capables de
valoriser le sol et qu'ils vont être
capables aussi de se développer dans des
contextes de sol on aura réduit le
travail du sol on aura associer d'autres
cultures et donc ça il ya tout ce champ
des possibles au niveau des variétés
c'est aussi un grand volet c'est
l'aménagement du territoire
l'aménagement du territoire il est
réalisé par les habitants et les
collectivités
il n'a pas d'objectifs économiques il a
un objectif d'attractivité de gestion du
bien commun c'est pour ça qu'il doit
être exemplaire dans la gestion durable
dans la conservation des ressources
naturelles
je dis bien exemplaires on a les
responsables des collectivités et nous
habitants la responsabilité de s'engager
notamment de la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols donc
notamment de rénover l'ancien d'utiliser
les friches de restaurer reconstruire
des soldats à partir d'anciennes friches
et ne pas consommer des nouvelles
surfaces
cultiver puisqu'on sait qu'on perd
l'équivalent en surface de sol
donc ce sol qui est qui héberge une
biodiversité exceptionnelle 1 40 % de la
biodiversité animale et on sait qu'on
perd l'équivalent en disant de la
surface d'un département français
c'est énorme donc c'est utiliser zéro
phyto là parce qu'on n'a pas d'objectif
du tout économique c'est uniquement la
production de services
c'est aussi gérer la biodiversité des
espaces publics des bordures de route
des parcs des cimetières et de faire
naître en fait de cultiver une diversité
végétale fleurissante qui va stimuler
une diversité d'insectes mais c'est
aussi laisser des plantes indigènes se
développer fleurir pour stimuler aussi
d'autres groupes d'animaux
c'est géré localement les résidus
organiques donc notamment éviter de les
exporter les faire en sorte de les gérer
localement puisque c'est une nourriture
pour la biodiversité du sol et c'est
aussi de développer des plans
territoriaux on a une action collective
locale sur la réduction des gaz à effet
de serre sur du des plans alimentaires
locaux sur la réduction de la qualité
l'amélioration de la qualité de l'air et
c'est aussi le dernier point l'éducation
des débuts favoriser l'éducation
intégrer ceux de cette démarche de
gestion de la biodiversité de la
conservation
dès le début dans les débuts de la
formation des élèves mais aussi la
formation dans les entreprises la
formation dans les associations dans le
cap d'une politique de responsabilité
environnementale et sociétale que toute
entreprise française ou association doit
réaliser et le point le dernier point
c'est aussi d'intégrer ça dans une
cohésion dans un vivre ensemble parce
que dès lors que vous n'aurez pas pris
en compte les personnalités les
activités de chacun
vous allez vous retrouver dans une
situation où vous allez mettre des
personnes de côté et qu'ils
n'accepteront pas en fait cette démarche
et qui répond contre cette démarche qui
mettront de l'énergie qui mettront du
lobby dans cette démarche et qui
impactera la vôtre donc c'est vraiment
réussir ensemble c'est la base de
développement durable donc en conclusion
c'est de vous dire que des paysages dans
dix ans dans dix ans des paysages plein
de vie plein de biodiversité c'est
possible mais alors dans ce cas là il
faudra nettoyer vos pare-brise de
voiture ok merci à vous
[Applaudissements]